>>> NOW OUR BEHIND CHI'S WALL
SERIES IN WHICH WE GO BEHIND THE
FANFARE OF THE CURRENT OLYMPIC
GAMES.
THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT HOPING TO
USE THE GAMES TO DISTRACT THE
WORLD FROM ITS CRACKDOWNS ON
FREEDOMS AND HUMANITY AND
GENOCIDE.
TODAY WE'LL LOOK AT HOW THEY
CENSURE THE FILM INDUSTRY.
THEY DON'T DO IT THROUGH DIRECT
CONTROL.
THEY DO IT THROUGH THEIR
ENORMOUS ECONOMIC LEVERAGE.
AND THE FEAR FROM STUDIOS ON
MISSING OUT ON A MARKET OF 1.4
BILLION PEOPLE IN CHINA.
HERE TO DISCUSS, ERIC SCHWARTZ,
THE HOLLYWOOD REPORTER.
HE'S AUTHOR OF A BRAND NEW BOOK
JUST RELEASED TODAY CALLED "RED
CARPET."
THANK YOU.
SO FOR BEING HERE.
ONE OF THE FILMS YOU WRITE
ABOUT, WHICH
IS FOUND IN TOP GUN, RELEASED IN
THE '80s, AND IT'S UPCOMING
SEQUEL.
WHEN THE ORIGINAL WAS RELEASED
IN '86, CHINA, NOT A CONCERN,
BUT FOR THE SEQUEL, THE STUDIO
HAS MADE A SIGNIFICANT CHANGE TO
THE LOOK ON THE JACKET OF THIS
ICONIC CHARACTER, MAVERICK.
EXPLAIN TO FOLKS WHAT'S GOING ON
HERE.
>> YEAH, YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT.
I MEAN, IN 1986, NOT ONLY WAS
HOLLYWOOD NOT CONCERNED ABOUT
THE CHINESE MARKET, BUT DO WE
HAVE AN EXAMPLE OF MORE RAH RAH
CINEMA THAN TOP GUN?
ENLISTMENT SHOT UP AFTER THAT
MOVIE CAME OUT.
THIS MORE RECENT VERSION WAS
ADVERTISED A COUPLE OF YEARS
AGO, THE TAIWANESE AND JAPANESE
FLAG HAD BEEN REMOVED.
THERE'S A CLEAR REASON WHY.
IN THE TIME BETWEEN THE ORIGINAL
AND THIS REBOOT, CHINA'S BOX
OFFICE HAS GROWN TO BE THE
BIGGEST IN THE WORLD AND ANY
MOVIE PRODUCED BY A HOLLYWOOD
STUDIO AS EXPENSIVE AS TOP GUN,
NEEDS THAT MARKET OFTEN TO TURN
A PROFIT.
SO THAT MEANS THAT EVEN DOWN TO
SOMETHING AS SMALL AS A FLAG ON
A JACKET MIGHT NEED TO BE
REMOVED IN CASE IT OFFENDS THE
CHINESE SENSORS WHO DECIDE
WHETHER IT WILL GET IN TO THOSE
THEATRES.
>> ANYTHING THAT CALLS INTO
QUESTION THE ONE CHINA POLICY IS
A POLITICAL THIRD REAL FOR THE
COMMUNIST GOVERNMENT.
YOU WRITE ABOUT BRAD PITT
STARRING IN THE 1997 FILM, SEVEN
YEARS IN TIBET.
AND BEING IN THAT FILM LANDED
BRAD PITT IN HOT WATER IS
CHINESE AUTHORITIES.
THEY ESSENTIALLY BANNED HIM AND
HIS FILM FROM CHINA FOR YEARS
AND YEARS.
TELL US MORE ABOUT THAT.
>> NOT ONLY THAT, THIS WAS IN
1997 WHEN THE CHINESE BOX OFFICE
WAS AN ECONOMIC AFTER THOUGHT
FOR STUDIOS, BUT SONY QUICKLY
LEARNED THAT IT WAS NOT JUST THE
STUDIO ACCESS THAT WAS
THREATENED ABOUT THE POLITICAL
EXILE AND HISTORY CHINA WOULD
R
RATHER NOT SEE, BUT SONY PROPER.
THIS EXPLAINS A LOT WHEN YOU SEE
HOW THESE CONGLOMERATES HAVE
TAKEN OVER HOLLYWOOD.
WHY A MOVIE THAT MIGHT SEEM LIKE
A MINOR PRODUCTION PRODUCED BY A
S
SUBDIVISION COMES AN ELEMENT.
SO IF DISNEY MAKES A MOVIE THAT
OFFENDS THE CHINESE AUTHORITIES,
IT'S NOT JUST THAT MOVIE THAT
MIGHT BE LOST, BUT ALSO THEME
PARK PLANS, CONSUMER PRODUCTS
PLANS.
THERE'S BILLIONS OF DOLLARS ON
THE LINE FOR ANY OF THESE
RELATIVELY SMALL INFRACTIONS.
>> ONE OF THE CRAZIEST EXAMPLES
IN YOUR BOOK IS THE 2012 REMAKE
OF THE FILM, RED DAWN, STARRING
ANOTHER TOP STAR, CHRIS
HEMSWORTH.
CHINA WAS SUPPOSED TO BE THE
ANTAGONIST IN THE MOVIE, BUT
AFTER THE FILM WAS SHOT, THEY
MADE A LITTLE BIT OF A CHANGE.
TELL US ABOUT THAT.
>> IT WAS A COSTLY CHANGE.
THE MOVIE HAD FINISHED FILMING
WITH THE STORY BEING CHINA
INVADING THE U.S. IN THIS
REMAKE.
OF COURSE IN THE ORIGINAL, IT
WAS THE SOVIETS.
THIS TIME, THEY UPDATED IT FOR
THE 2010s AND MADE IT CHINA AND
THEN WHEN CHINA MADE IT CLEAR
THAT THEY WERE GOING TO BE VERY
ANGRY IF THIS MOVIE CAME OUT AS
IT WAS SHOT, MGM SPENT A MILLION
DOLLARS HIRING A VISUAL EFFECTS
FIRM HERE IN BURBANK TO GO IN
AND SWAP OUT THE FLAGS, THE
DIALOGUE, AND MAKE IT A NORTH
KOREAN INVASION.
NOW, CRITICS AND EVEN THE
WRITERS OF THE FILM ITSELF
POINTED OUT IT WAS A LITTLE LESS
PLAUSIBLE THAN A CHINESE
INVASION, BUT NONETHELESS, THIS
LESSON WAS ABSORBED BY ALL OF
HOLLYWOOD BECAUSE EVER SINCE
THEN, THAT CAME OUT